good afternoon this is Matt Welch
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine I'm
here in Denver at the Democratic
National Convention we're here on day 2
which is renewing America's Promise day
where the Democrats tell us everything
that we wanted to know about the economy
and more as all libertarians and
freedom-loving people really want to
know is well how will that translate
into policy on January 21st or whenever
inauguration day is with a newly
energized Democratic majority in both
Congress and the Senate Dave Weigel
you've written about this a lot tell us
concretely what Democrats have in store
what have they been rubbing their hands
over for lo these past eight years well
they want higher taxes that's not much
of a page-turner they went to get rid of
the Bush tax cuts and increase tax
revenues and who's you know better than
middle class which they're going to
define down a define down pretty well
they want to make it really easy to
unionize without a secret ballot that
issues being a you know pushed out of
the weeds a little bit by activists here
but a theme I keep hearing is confidence
about Obama but confidence is
strategizing that how to get to 60
functional Senate votes they really had
they really want a majority that can't
be broken in order to kind of enact the
policies that you know Bill Clinton
would have done if you had a a third
term Jim Cavanaugh you were at a couple
of events this morning having to do with
the economy in housing what did you see
I saw that all of my liberal buddies are
right that bloodthirsty corporate fat
cats are underwriting all of these
things the one event was sponsored by
financial services lobbyist the other
one was from the national association of
realtors and you know we should always
be a little mindful of the difference
between rhetoric and reality and the
possibility that just naked political
corruption might end up saving us and
and also remind ourselves that we have a
democratic nominee who defines the
middle class as people making two
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year so
we'll say
Mike Flynn there's been a lot of press
coverage recently about Barack Obama
that he's really interested in
surrounding himself with the best
researchers and he's very pragmatic
you've actually worked with him in
Illinois can you talk a little bit about
his receptiveness two ideas that he
doesn't agree with yeah I will and you
know he does like surround himself with
a lot of different viewpoints he done
then just votes left I was working with
him in Illinois in a tort reform issue
and when I was there all the cynical
hard-bitten like contract lobbyist were
gushing that I should go talk to Senator
Obama that you know he would be open and
here we could move him on the issue and
I had a very very pleasant chat with him
and we had a really good discussion and
then he voted the other way and it's
kind of like the Daniel Patrick Moynihan
syndrome you remember that conservatives
just always praised his rhetoric but
then lament that he always just vote is
a doctrinaire leftist and that's what
I've seen with Senator Obama I mean he
talks a really good game and is open to
different viewpoints but at the end of
the day he's going to be a leftist well
that's it a little preview for you
tonight enjoy the speeches in the
conventions God knows we're going to try
and for recent TV this is matt welch
Mike Flynn Dave waggle and Tim Cavanaugh
thanks and good afternoon